so I recently played one of my best
title Tuesdays in a long time it was a
stack tournament there was Magnus Hikaru
farouza Fabiano
I didn't manage to play any of them but
I played a handful of very strong Grand
Masters had multiple upsets I played one
of my best games of the year involved
sacking a ton of material to just crush
a GM and I also had multiple games going
over a hundred moves so my longest games
ever in toggle Tuesday it was a fun
tournament I will say my voice was not a
hundred percent I've been recovering
from a cold but it's been getting better
every day and hoping to do more YouTube
contents coming up so do stay tuned and
I hope you enjoy the video wow look at
the stock lineup
Magnus hicario Fabiano mvl
jaspam for ruja Duda kramnik is a 24th
seed
Eric Hansen is 37th
okay
playing this person
I'll play a qgd
I've been looking into the sign recently
but actually I was studying this this
morning
I had a few Blitz Games off stream
earlier that uh featured this position
it's not the most typical line
uh yeah generally Queen B3 is met with
C5
and there's cases where the queen can be
misplaced
I guess there is dc5
dc5 maybe A5
or queen A5
actually probably Queen A5
like the point of C5 not only I defend
the bishop I prepare this there's cases
where C4 happens as well
and of course I pressure the center
if E3 I probably played 94
okay you can take the pawn
so considering 94 right away
it looks a little bit risky I'm leaving
the pod undefended
kind of relying on tactics
and it takes I think I take with Bishop
takes and then Bishop F5
it's still Bishop by five
there's Bishop B5
this is like Castle first
I could grab the bishop pair
I think just Bishop at five first
Bishop B5 is King f8
and then the Bishops of Target and the
queens of targets
okay so I'm like fully developed and
trying to pressure
why in every which way
it's a fun opening
I mean the threat right away is probably
Knight G3 like hitting the queen and
hitting the Rook
so that's a move
huh
if I take
I think I just take on C3 with a knight
and then move back
so hitting the queen
regardless of what takes I play 94. I'm
subjecting myself to checks
but I think the the situation for light
with the Knight and Battery hitting D2
it should be okay for me
it's very Tactical
okay so I Do cover D6
G7 is
available for capture but then I play
this Knight and Bishop are attacked
okay so this is
a good sign
and just castling
anything better G6
but then Knight E4
Queen B5
you're just castling
I might not be that much better but I'm
up on time
Rook C8 Navy to watch out for the fork
here's some D4 idea
or just G6
wow
I think I can play Knight G7
oh but that allows an H6
what about this move
I was moved as everything
Alicia is a rook friends of fork night's
still hanging
yeah too many things hanging
be careful
yeah this works
okay
there is one last try for white to take
the Knight and play Knight G4
but then the final position there's no
way to actually win material
the king of two is off limits
okay uh that was a fun game to start the
tournament
um
I will say
I I was reluctant to actually say this
during the game I did mention this like
months ago I'm working on a course
against one D4
and there's been some stalls with uh
actual production but
um this is one of the lines I'm I'm
working on for the course
because it's it's so Dynamic and there's
a lot of ways white can go astray
and it's I think a great way to play for
a win from especially from a line that
looks solid for white at first
like there's a lot of potential like if
E3 there's 94 and G5 ideas
so it's similar to ragozin
but a little bit more offbeat there's a
lot of details I still have to figure
out like I want to make something very
comprehensive
and
probably add a video components for now
I'm just uh I'm working on like
thoroughly annotated files
I'm not sure exactly when release date
will be your pricing or anything but
do stay tuned yeah Cambridge Springs as
well yeah this uh actually this
repertoire is
um
conducive for Cambridge Springs because
if Bishop G5 which is one of the most
common moves then C6 E3 and this is
another way another very fighting way to
play against D4
and okay at the highest level maybe a
little bit dubious but it's still a nice
surprise weapon
diggleren beat uh prognananda with us
Carlson's played this a few times
okay play grustamov
play E4 I usually play D4 against first
time off mix it up a little bit
we have a French
okay inspired by jingle around him
I'll play I'll play a very sharp line
I'm gonna take some risk here
oh this one
Bishop E2
wait what's the line here
I think it's Bishop E2 this is it's
probably no it's Bishop D3
and here okay and castle
foreign
s
D1
pretty sure it's H4
it's been so long though
is it A3 I'm playing way too slowly
holding off an H4 because I I just
forgot the theory
I think this would be two
okay so it's somewhat of a gamut
now probably H4
if the H pawn moves I take the knights
that a four may be coming
Knight H4 even
a confusing position
that move I'll admit I kind of forgot
about
I'm down two Pawns
but on the right sidelined
okay I'm stacking a third Pawn
I just want to get rid of the darks for
a bishop
okay Queen here
so it's a three Pawn gamut
and G6 G4 Knight G7 Queen H6 is
interesting
there's Knight G3 though
that should also be okay Knight G3 I
play Rook C1
and the eventual ideas to come in and
checkmates
a very confusing position
okay I'm stacking a bishop
I just want to checkmates
if Knight E4 I sacked The Rook
F6 so Bishop comes to life after and
meet
so how does life defend
we've got seven
eventually five Queen B2
maybe just Rook beam one first
Bishop D4 is interesting
huh
not much time
I wasn't entirely sure there
hmm
I want to win G6
so 95 I take I sacked the other Rook
threat is to take on f8
wait what
does this actually work
wait I'm meeting right it's meeting two
Main and two
wow okay
I sacked so many things that game
including most of my time
well that was actually a really nice uh
a nice attack
I mean I
I really committed myself to going all
out and some somehow it works
uh
I'm pretty sure H4 was a theory right
I'll have to
um there's no opening book here
off to look at the opening book
I studied this about a year ago so I
played this line in Iceland
it's uh this Gambit line it's super
risky but it's kind of risky for both
sides I mean on the surface without
checking the engine too much this is
probably
one of the most fielded games I played
in a long time
just the the idea is like sacking and
going all out and then just the
weirdness with Knight G3 and
going straight for the attack and it
almost didn't work
like here
initially I wanted to
I just wanted to win back material but
then I don't really have a great
follow-up I was very fortunate to find
this move
and it still almost doesn't work
because initially I want to take here
um but then after it takes oh I have
Queen
or maybe this maybe this works
there's not enough three and the King
runs to G3
but yeah Queen F6 was just force meat
yeah I'll have to do like more analysis
later but I mean this game alone was
probably a very YouTube worthy so if
you're watching in the future on YouTube
uh
don't forget to watch live on Twitch
playing uh playing engines
I'll play London
because Ninja really mixes things up as
we see
uh and there's a line actually there's a
line that I have in mind here
okay D6 never mind play C4
or no
late night C3
E4
yeah we have some like Sicilian type
position
already threatening this
0.85 A3 it's 95 ideas
and Visually this looks like a a good
version of Sicilian for lights
just more development
uh there's this move
Bishop C4 first
A4
try and keep the pace here
like C5 Knight D5
you see three
so I want to get a good night versus bad
Bishop scenario
[Music]
C3 is maybe not necessary if I take
first
no C3 is generally a useful move
F5 might happen at some point
okay what about B4
V4 Knight D7 Rook C1
okay
might have to play Rook fc1
just so there's a line Knight F6 Queen
D3 Queen C6 so a pawn needs to be
defended
and in this line uh I play Knight T2
the dream is to maneuver the Knight to
D5 but it takes a long time
I need to have five like
maybe eventually after three
the G5 is coming
play C4
D4 B5
pawns on light squares work well with a
Dark Sword Bishop
and a G4
there's A5
it's not a fauna
a little bit passive but
I have ideas
of G5 uh
oh what to do
there there
Rook D1 first
no
I could sack
let's try this
I'm not better anymore
this move
start with this move
might not be so much worse though
the king will come to D3 and I keep C4
defended
E5 idea
okay H5 maybe Rook out three
foreign
oh had some chances
even in the end game although maybe it's
already lost I have to play this move
this might even be winning
Rook C3
oh wait oh in this position though Rook
C3
and then
Black's only way of making progress is
by doing this
but that gives me time to walk the king
back
yeah this should be winning
uh
oh it's so sad
yeah Rook C3 yeah White's winning here
I was just in the mindset so
Sprint thinking back
sort of one prophylactic move really
slows back down
an earlier
yeah earlier like this was still a three
result game
um I was worse so
kind of chances I think in the middle
game I was just better
but it required a lot of like precise
kind of patient play at some point I
should have yeah like Rook C2 just get
the The Rook off this diagonal
in 93 just allowed Bishop G5
that was round of three
still good result overall
playing this person
of solomoni okay
okay
back to D4
uh
wait what am I doing this is uh still
standard
I'll play um play the slide
Page Six
the casa Corley variation
yeah white still laid Queen C2
maybe it doesn't make a huge difference
huh
maybe this is the wrong setup
can be five now
the idea is to eventually maneuver this
Knight to C4
I think via EA to D6
okay if I take I'm taking Queen D6
usually the Knight wants to go here
I do have an idea
Queen A2
we need to Knight B6 Queen A7 Knight C4
foreign
there's a funny move Queen I've hates
I just keep the attack prevent Queen A2
and after Knight C5 play Queen eight
I do allow 96.
I'm getting the a file eventually
getting Knight C4
maybe as a bishop just moves back maybe
this
still be okay with the trade
I'm not a four might be coming
foreign
A3
I'm allowing Knight A5 the Knight C4
so hitting the queen and knights
really
take and play B4
that'd be two
winning I'm trying to win the pawn there
is A6 but then B3 B2
we might end up Trading
also Bishop C8
E4 might happen in the right moment
okay but then I take everything and win
the pawn
foreign
position
and the idea is to play Knight C4
but then E4 again
I can't allow E4
ideas to play F5 Maybe
the wrong idea
okay
super risky
it's a good move
am I just losing
I don't see what to do
yeah I think it's just losing
uh tricky position though
yeah Queen B8 and A7
maybe Queen E3
oh but there's no check
yeah white doesn't hang the queen
ah I tried
uh
uh here goes my time
oh thank you someone getting merch
uh what to do
okay that was that was round four so we
have a break finally
this is a one last chance in Queen D6
so now I can go ahead and like hopefully
analyze all my games I want to check
this last game
I think my opponent was like prepared
for this
uh kind of tricky opening move order
if you didn't play Queen C2
and yeah maybe this calls for a
different approach
because 986 makes sense when the Queen's
on C2 because it provokes A3
but we just didn't have to play
okay white still played A3
ah maybe it's still playable
yeah it was a little bit worse
if I ever have chances in this game
I think like later it got interesting
though
it's still better for whites
yeah the problem for black is these
pieces aren't as good as these pieces
and with a like two pass pawns on the
board
the placement of the minor pieces really
matters
after it was a good move
yeah opponent played a good game overall
like at some point I self-destructed but
I had to play very accurately
like B3 Knight C4
okay this game I checked this game yeah
man this uh
the second round game was so nice
I'm a little bit scared to use the
engine because it's going to criticize
probably so much of my play
I wanted to check the theory though
because I've had this position
the game I've studied was uh mvl Punk
ratov
I actually view this
they played a pretty deep theoretical
line
yeah very sharp variation
so H4 is uh the theory here
but A3 is still playable
if ideas to yeah just expand and allow
for Bishop B2
which I did play
wait let me check uh where's the where's
the timer
oh my game started
and it didn't make any noise okay
okay uh thanks people for telling me the
game started
giving some small timeouts here
okay
that's a good move order
let's play classically
okay so I'm down about a minute
and time flew by really quickly there
yeah we're keeping things simple
four looks nice
Texas
I'm briefly appealing but
okay so C3 doesn't work because Bishop
D5 check
it's about five ideas
Bishops are a little bit tender
I guess this is playable
take with
tempted to take with Pawn actually
Rook D3
work F3 perhaps
five
I'm still down about a minute but
physician looks nice
if it was pinned
where does the king go King moves here I
have this move
he moves the other way
I think I I win The Rook in the end
oh no oh there's that move
95.
let's start with this 95.
to take
I think this works
not sure though
it's like Queen defends uh from the
distance which could be useful in some
lines
the main idea is after ponte's working
one
I guess there's Rook
Rook ae8
a train
well the ending should still be
preferable I think
yeah even take your first
allowing Rook G5
it's risky
G4
it's crazy if this works
messed up
or did I
okay
I could have easily lost that
I wasn't clear until like
I'm headphones are flags
oh
okay
yeah if you're just joining uh this is
title Tuesday that was my fifth round
game
um
not the cleanest
I mean I I joined late to the game
uh I got a little bit too carried away
with analysis
next game will be starting
probably in a few moments
okay
another grand master opponent
let's play E4
E4 served me while another game
A6
I'll admit I have no like formal study
here
but
try and make it work
so the idea is to take just went upon
there's also ideas of playing C4 D5
wow
Bishop B4
but if I take on E5
I might be walking into some Theory I'm
temporarily up upon
okay probably losing it back at some
point
some A3
maybe Castle first
uh
if I play Bishop
C5 looks interesting
maybe a lot of Rook C8
then Bishop B4 Knight C6
ideas to prevent black from castling
it's 1966 Bishop 83 probably or Vision
D6
play H3
and I don't have to move the bishop to
interesting
Point D4 take
I think just A3
it should be roughly equal
got a little bit of time
leaving some tension
if e 5 Square could be nice for the
knights like combined with F4 someday
I think I'm threatening to take take
take take and then take take take
maybe take your first
does that work
I don't think king of six prevents that
uh there's Knight C3 though
and C3
if I take your first
take take
and it's close to a draw
yeah there's Rook C3
I have check first actually
I didn't see this when I initially
calculated it but it's a useful move I
guess I could have taken menchat
but ideas to meet Rook C3 with Rook E3
up a pawn but okay it should still be
equal
yeah I think it's just a draw
the Box clings for a win though oh
the king's cut off
in like King can walk in
the time-wise I have to be very careful
five idea
foreign
it's Lucina position
I learned this when I was nine years old
what am I doing
there we go
okay
uh I mean he really wanted to win but uh
over pushed a little bit
let's go
Eric thank you for the karaoke trap
video slash study oh my pleasure games
with it oh nice to hear
okay playing Conrad Holt
still trying to recover from that last
game
and that E5 is a small inaccuracy it's
still playable but
as far as I know although usually the
queen is on C2 and the Rooks on E8
wow
take
G5
okay I just play Knight C6 takes takes
uh uh C4 is a move
there should be sevens to move it Bishop
B7
took a while to even consider this move
okay we'll get some iqp position
oh
Queen D6
very tricky
wait Queen D6 was hangs a queen what am
I thinking
Queen B6
Queen B6 is similar
I spent a lot of time there so there's
Bishop F6 and then takes a knight
ideas to eventually get in D4
and I was just thinking about this line
I could take and play 94.
I couldn't take the pawn because Bishop
he's seven but now I'm threatening to
take the pawn
and after it takes takes the structure
is not great looking but I mean White
House weaknesses too
I mean two pawns are currently attacked
really
that's a fancy move
G5 doesn't quite work
I guess that's it's a playable move
ah Bishop B7 wow
I don't take
what a move
it's not the move I wanted to play
didn't see anything else so
now I take with check
two
it might has cop here might be
threatening this
probably not
Jake
it's got a rook and play
thank you
from SQL material I'm probably worse as
a digital pair
I thought they could play this
take on E2
very clever
for Rook D1 I take on D3
now Rook is is actually fine here
or is it
took me a long time to see that
it should just be winning now
Let's Not freak out
foreign
it
technically could use some work here
there we go
another 100 plus move game
okay oh man
yeah there's no 50 move roll when I make
like occasional pawn moves
oh man
I was around seven
and I had to be one of the final games
so what's my score
the five out of seven
wow Chris you having a great tournament
where is Magnus
Magnus hicaro and Fabiano and furuja all
had five out of five
at some point
Fusion now is five and a half
Magnus has six
or Carlo is six okay
okay
these games
uh okay playing Serana
I beat Serrano once with a Stafford
I'm gonna use an E4 player
maybe he mixes okay he mixes it up
just play my usual
um let's play Let's play this bishop D6
line
or no let's play the um
Red Robinson variation
so there's castling
and then B5 okay
Pleasant line but I mean
it's like roughly equal I think
Rook B8
and queen B6 first
night discoveries aren't too harmful
A6
uh there's Knights ah he's creating some
issues
it's okay
Rook be adhered to
takes takes
there's 94
and it Rook B8
leaning towards Rook B it's not happy
with it though
so I take Queen C4
maybe just Bishop E7
this was my initial impression
I spent a lot of time there so if Bishop
B4 Rook B8
to play this nah this is just not good
for me
Queen B8
yeah like barely holding on
just losing the exchange
what to do
and try and fight
foreign
's coming
let's try this
doesn't work
we'll have to try something
I have nine seconds left ah
rates pinned in two directions
some B3
okay so I want to take a pawn with the
bishop
I have one second left how's that even
possible
so I fell down to zero
ah
or White's Chucks rookie for King f8
how am I still alive
no
I flagged
ah okay the move I was gonna play is
losing anyway
right
Queen D Eric G4
uh it's so hard to play on the
increments because like to play a move
it takes at least half seconds
but the final position
like I have am I winning
I'm winning with Rook H1
or no I'm not Queen's defended
for a moment I was thinking um
I have the skewer
but the pawn defends the queen
but still Interesting Man
yeah I was at one second here
yeah how is that possible
because
while leechas operates in hundreds of
seconds
but trust.com only operates in tenths of
so that meant I fell down to zero
but I didn't flag
I can't recall if I've seen this before
server side desync
so does that mean I actually had more
time or
I had better ping
so hundreds of seconds not displaying
because more often it'll say like at the
end it'll say the move didn't reach the
server
I mean next time I shouldn't get myself
in these situations
here we go
so that was the timer at the timer uh
tab
I don't know why it didn't make that
sound earlier
okay playing Greek player
back to London been mixing it up with
openings this is white
E4 and E4
I'm at this line I don't like know too
much Theory but
it's supposed to be okay for whites
9 D4 first
if any two maybe commenting
yeah so managed to develop all the minor
pieces
some tension between the knights and
Bishops
95 that I just plunder upon
I guess I kind of did
I have B4
I think I have to try B4
just a lapse of uh
of alertness there
yeah this is not a good position
I'll try and fight but
I'm not happy with the opening outcome
the lights are a bit awkward so that's
something
although yeah we are trading
the queen B6 is coming
it's Queen B6 I have C3
what about Queen E2
maybe C3 first
over defending the Knight
E5 is coming
doesn't work
yeah this is gonna be tough
and they're threatening maybe this
is a good move
although if I take
take with pod
so Knight takes takes I take on E5
here's uh some nagging pressure
trying to exploit B7 maybe Knight C5
and if takes take Simon B7
E4 could happen any moment
and the structure is so bad
it's equal material though so it's some
hope
so I defend the pawn
all my pawns are isolated and black has
such better structure than me
and taking the ip5 is probably possible
with A2 in the end but then at least we
trade off some Pawns
if you like plans to bring the king to
D3
or maybe Knight D4
let's see what black does
actually if if take on A5 maybe I throw
in the C4 move
play this first
and this is what I want just a messy
situation
foreign
again with the one second
okay no still Matrix as my third game
over 100 moves
oh man
the second Lucina position to
I was worse most of the game I don't
know if I maybe had chances
taking the bishop is the wrong decision
because the night's very strong here
if I was a good move though
uh maybe I have Rook
The Rook F3 doesn't work blunder is
everything
yeah I had in mind to play A6 at some
point
but never actually did
I think A6 makes a ton of sense here
though
because then after it takes at least I
got the pass a pawn
better counter play
okay good game what a fight
uh I assume next round we'll be starting
very soon like one one game left oh
first time here after seeing clips of me
on Tick Tock for weeks now oh wow
wait clips
Clips on tick tock on my Tick Tock
Channel or other people's Tick Tock
channels
I think there's a handful of like
channels that just repost my content
without maybe asking for permission
but uh good to have you here
I dabbled a little bit with posting like
a few uh
a few weeks ago
I know chess was a big Trend these days
welcome to all the new people
uh if you're joining uh just now it's
titled Tuesday
I think this is a second to last game
G3 okay so E5
um
I'll play like a reverse buffing setup
this is more of a system based opening
the Knight wants to come here
D5 is not playable
F5 looks playable
yeah it's a very typical structure
where
there will be a lot of tension
Sometimes the best thing to do in these
situations is just like improve the
pieces as much as possible
and get ready for the position to open
up
King is generally a bit safer on h8
but now what to do
and Knight G8
a lot of moves to consider here
each six is a move
and maybe h16 H7
some small Improvement
okay I see what white wants to do
and grip T8 might be the same move
so there's some A6 combined with a lot
of tactics
thank you Shadow Bean
not sure what I'll do with Bishop E3
that's a good move
take take
I might have to take on
I might just be in trouble here
or maybe I just weather the storm
I feel like I might be losing a pawn
from the C5 is a bit tender in some
lines
and there's so much tension
between the knights ponds Queens
so B6 B6 at least defends C5
I've always been surely what to think
about here there's some B5 resource at
some point
and I'm not sure what my next improving
move will be
I think at some point I should probably
relieve tension
your rookie Eights
tick tick
maybe rookie 8 first
no longer caring about a file
I have to take with
have to take on Knights
everything still looks solid
so I'm threatening to take the bishop
takes like Fork
pause is a little bit overworked
take with Pawn
this is still an idea
wow really
wow
yeah that's a good move
um I have to
just deal with it
I can't take the knights
but there's still play like Knight C4 I
have E4
D5 may be coming
might even be winning back the pawn
takes and C4
oh
I have no idea what's going on anymore
Rook T3
play this
okay
and the final position oh no my Bishop
but then it's uh it'd be made in three
okay
I'm not sure like if White's white
should have some defense here
although Bishop F2 there's probably Pawn
E3
Rook off to
and these pawns are monstrous should be
winning for black
oh
Rook fp1 ah
multi-purpose creating Escape square and
getting some counter play
I think I would have played this
and somehow this is a draw
is white has a blockade
okay
six out of ten one more game
I forget exactly who drop stone is
uh
oh perovian yeah strong Grandmaster
yeah most of the names are like public
who is this
oh geharo okay
yeah playing a strong GM from Spain
from a Kali system
huh
I might try and play more aggressively
here
like Queen side Castle
and sometimes risky
let's try it
if rookie won I think I can take on D4
because Bishops he two ideas
okay 94 here
he wants to play 93 Knight B5
I could consider taking actually
and then 94
. yeah because the bishop was like
impeding on my planet of G5
usually Bishop takes V1 is not a great
positional decision but
I think it was somewhat Justified there
so I have G5 here
of F5
G5 I mean there's takes takes
okay just H6
I really want to get an H5
I also want to get an F5 so
I had to choose one
and King is relatively safe
in one danger is if the position opens
up the Bishops can really flourish but
light's pretty strong for the time being
Rook g8s
C4 is probably coming
hard to achieve though
Bishop B5 might be coming
I think I just moved back
and C4
C4 G4
because it weakens D4
I guess now I'm ready to play this
my H5 C4 G4
that's tricky though
if I play G4 right away
G4 and H for F4
let's go for that
not sure about it
has some spice to it
should have kept in mind I forgot I can
just take the bishop whenever
am I threatening to suck probably not
Ah that's a move
okay so I have F3
Knight G5 which is interesting
does allow Queen G4
but maybe I do it
some potential mating ideas
if I take
oh
that's not good
yeah this is not good
1.1 seconds
you're just calculating the winning
ending
really
oh no it's this morning uh what to do
there's one final trap
take it take it take it uh
okay
oh well played
I don't think I have anything in the
like this final ending
B5 is too slow
good game
wow good job oh wow there's a three-way
tie for first at least
wait it was an eight-way tie for first
and we all got the the best tie breaks
so mvl Magnus farouza Chris you
uh around I think this is Jacobian
right yeah
all right well that was a fun tournament
I feel like the quality of my games were
much better compared to previous weeks
in a bit better form today
still some uh some tough losses but like
every single loss I think was very hard
fought